In bobsleigh, luge and skeleton, collectively
known as the sliding sports
crashes are an inevitability.
"... Tearing down the hill!"
"Oh my goodness!"
It's traumatic.
It's aggressive.
It's anything that is extreme times ten.
To think that somebody has gone to the Olympics
without having had an episode like a crash
is very unlikely.
Christina Smith is a trailblazer
in the sport of bobsled.
"...one of the most experienced drivers in
the field..."
But in the years after she retired, she started
to experience troubling symptoms.
Long-term, short-term memory loss, anxiety,
fear, depression.
The inability to really stay focused
and have emotional regulation.
Eventually, she was diagnosed with
a traumatic brain injury
even though she’d never once
been diagnosed with a concussion.
Just the fact that I was losing something
of myself that I didn't realize
potentially could have been contributed
to the affects of
the multiple runs, multiple vibrations,
the concussions that actually I'd never been
diagnosed with my entire career.
There's growing evidence that, when it comes
to the sliding sports
catastrophic concussions like
the ones you get from crashing
might not be the main driver of brain injury.
Microconcussions are.
Concussions so mild they can often go unnoticed
and so common that they have
a special name: sled head.
To understand how sled head happens, you have
to know how concussions work.
Your brain is soft with a jello-like consistency.
Normally, it’s pretty well protected
by layers of bone and tissue.
But if your head gets hit or shook around
or just moves too fast,
your brain can shift inside
its protective casing
bumping up against the sides of your skull.
When that happens, the fragile neurons that
make up your brain can stretch or even tear.
And when they tear, they release toxins that
can harm other neurons
triggering a chain reaction of damage, and
leaving your brain vulnerable to further injury.
Concussions are serious and come with
scary side effects.
But for the most part they heal
with time and rest.
The problem is not all concussions are obvious.
Hey, if you got out of that sled and you're
just a little bit dizzy
and then all of a sudden it's like,
"No, I'm good."
And you're full of adrenaline.
And essentially if you have the will and the
desire
to get back up and dust yourself off
and do it again, so be it.
But even a mild concussion is a concussion.
And if it’s not given time to heal, the
damage can become more serious
and cause more enduring symptoms.
That kind of scattered brain and, you know,
inability to focus.
So a lot of those little things...
It’s all those little things that
make up sled head.
From the outside, sledding sports look smooth.
A graceful, if fast, run down an icy track.
But, inside a sled, things look and feel
very different.
Sledding is, in a way, inherently brain rattling.
Even during the smoothest ride,
a sledder is tossed about.
Shaken, bumped, whipped around corners.
It's so extreme that if you haven't
gone to the bathroom
if you haven't blown your nose and if you
haven't stretched
you have no idea what's going to
happen to you.
There's a lots of bouncing and
people moving quickly.
Their heads are going everywhere.
Peter McCarthy is a neurophysiologist
whose research focuses on how various forces
effect our bodies.
He told me that sledding is a lot like a very,
very intense roller coaster.
They're rickety and they've got lots of vibrations
and they've got high g-turns.
G, as in g-force.
Roughly, the force of gravity
or acceleration on an object.
Going for a stroll on earth, you’re experiencing
1 g-force.
Riding an average roller coaster, around 5.
Military fighter pilots average 9 gs.
And the average football player receives 103
gs when hit during a game.
The g-force of an average concussion
is hard to measure or generalize
but one researcher found that most diagnosed
ones have a g-force between 85 and 95.
And, when another researcher
measured the g-force
of his own skeleton ride at the
Whistler Olympic track
at its highest, here, he recorded 84.5 g-force.
That spike only happened for a few milliseconds.
But spikes like it can happen with every run.
And then there are the vibrations.
Long term exposure to vibrations can lead
to a range of serious health issues
affecting basically all of your body’s systems.
There are even international guidelines
about how much vibration someone should encounter
in a given period.
And when Peter attached devices
on the helmets, sleds, and backs
of skeleton athletes to measure how much they
were encountering
preliminary results showed that
doing just one run
could potentially put you over the limit.
Sled Head is a phenomenon which seems to be
neurological in nature.
And as a consequence ,we're thinking maybe
vibrations are getting through into the brain
and that could be the cause of it.
All racing sports deal with both g-force and
vibration to a certain extent
but normally they get dispersed
throughout your body.
When you’re in a sled there's not much between
your brain and the vibrations.
I was so close and low that I had
chips of paint and scratches on the side of
my helmet from
just tapping going all the way down the track.
And so, you know, of course, I get out and
I haven't had a crash or nothing would happen
but that just built up over time like a snowball.
Years after she stopped sledding,
Christina went to a specialist
who ran a test called a quantitative electroencephalogram,
or qEEG.
The beauty of this is that it can actually
see where your brain is firing,
not firing at all, or partially or too much.
When doctors analyzed her results,
they saw this:
roughly, the red shading correlates
to over-activation.
In a brain that hadn’t experienced trauma
those areas would be white.
It was like a a-ha moment for me.
It really highlighted, you know what I had
been going through and I was no longer
hard on myself.
It was very common to overlook our own experiences
because we're always about
the show must go on.
There’s only so much we can learn from
one person’s brain scans.
Or the data from a few runs.
It needs an objective assessment
of the discipline, basically.
Because if we just allow people
to keep doing this
we don't know if it's safe for them to do
that with the intensity they're doing it.
One way to better look after sliding athletes
is to require them to wear a monitor.
A simple sensor system could
detect an impact
and have that per person immediately
flagged for treatment
and possibly sitting out until
they've recovered fully.
And there are some exciting developments
in tech
like virtual reality training
that reduces ice time.
Or an FDA-approved collar that increases
blood volume in your brain
giving it better cushioning.
In the future, new materials that could
dampen vibration in the sled.
But the federation that controls sliding sports
needs to make these available.
Or even mandatory.
And I feel that that's something that hopefully
a way forward, though, who knows?
It depends on international bodies to make
these legislative changes
and start looking at their athletes as actually
things that keep the body alive.
The athletes are the lifeblood of any sport
and you need to protect them, in my mind.